it's gonna be fun it's gonna be fun to
see everybody's different
zooms already like looking at some of
the ones that have done it's been crazy
I jumped in a 21st birthday that was its
own thing they were playing beer pong in
their houses they had like one guy had
all these Solo cups lined up on his
thing and they were bouncing this and
and and another one I jumped in was a
teacher conference they sent a blink
they're like hey you want to jump in and
the these elementary school teachers in
Illinois and I'm like okay let's see
another one was health care workers and
some of them are pretty it's inspiring
you see these people they're just
staying connected any way they can this
song originated in 2018 me and my best
buddy Kelly Lovelace who writes a lot of
songs with me I'd add this title for a
long time but I wanted to write it in a
way that didn't feel hokey you know that
just felt sort of inclusive and you know
and then we rewrote that course and the
thing that was nuts was as this pandemic
began everybody adopted this catchphrase
we're all in this together and I had had
this song rolling around in my head
wherever you are tonight whatever you're
going through grab a longneck bottle or
a big old pipe let's all head
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and then all of a sudden everything
changes and the same lyrics means
something new it's like when you're
right we're all in this together there's
no I of beer in 2018 it's one thing when
you say that now it's a it's different
it's not just a it's not just a we'll
get through whatever you're going
through thing it's literally a rallying
cry it's a battle it's a fight song
it's like wheat you know what weird this
is how people are coping